okay last question today is from tara
tara said hey what's the worst movie you
guys have seen in its entirety I have a
pretty good filter for what movies I'm
going to like and not like foot so with
books for example i rarely start reading
a book that I end up not liking and I
stopped reading it because I look at
particular award lists and and sort of
filter what I'm going to read given a
limited amount of time through some
reliable sources and the same thing the
movies two movies that I got roped into
going to buy friends that I thought were
just atrocious now these may not be that
bad because I I have such a filter for
what movies I'm even willing to see the
2003 remake or version of iteration of
the Hulk i SAT through and I just
thought it was so stupid and disasters
and just a really terrible movie that I
didn't like at all and then the other
one and it's actually former producer
lewis who who suggested going to see
this one the punisher which I don't know
if the punisher is a superhero or an
antihero I don't know it was so bad and
I I don't remember if it was Hugh
Jackman who was in that movie I don't
remember what year is what it was from I
remember being miserable watching that
in the movie theatre from five minutes
in until the end and i SAT through it
yeah I mean being in a movie theater
Yuki there's no escape to you can you
can try to doze off but if you're
anything like me i can't sleep sitting
down rice kinda have to put up with it
what about you for the worst movie that
you sat through so I'm really not much
of a movie movie goer but there's this
movie called Manos the hands of fate
which is critically acclaimed to be the
worst movie of all time and I thought
you know maybe this is so bad it'll be
good in some respects this 1960s horror
film that's just super low budget and
you can tell they filmed it ansan a
camera that could only film 30 seconds
at a time so there's these just
continuity errors all over the place
there's these jump cuts where there
shouldn't be the camera couldn't record
any audio so they had voice actors dub
over yeah all the the dialogue and you
can tell they only had about two or
three voice actors the whole thing is
just a mess I mean how did you even hear
about such a movie it's it's gotten to
be kind of a cult following the cult
following around it and John so so I
took interest in the whole thing is pre
on
youtube you can watch it now because the
copyrights well expired uh but really
there's no redeeming qualities to it in
just use gonna be kicking yourself after
the end of it I've started some
documentaries on netflix and then
changed my mind after about 10 minutes
and with documentaries I uh if I there's
so many documentaries i have on my
netflix queue that if i don't really
feel like i'm going to get something out
of it after about 20 minutes 25 minutes
particularly some of these documentaries
are only an hour and 10 minutes if I'm
twenty-five or thirty five percent of
the way through it and I'm still not
feeling like I'm getting anything out of
it I will usually just cut it
particulars loop particularly since my
documentary watching time is pretty
limited what's interesting you're able
to persevere through books more than you
are movies and i just read builder is
about it I think I filter is better
because I use the netflix recommended
based on your watch history a lot and
sometimes the algorithm is just not
picking things that are get that good
for me but with books you know certain
friends will recommend books and I'll
trust those recommendations they're
generally good or once there's an author
I like I'll get a lot of stuff from that
author that type of thing I think my
filter is just better with books than it
is documentaries yeah I can totally see
it and uh i guess i would recommend
manos the hands of fate all right we
will that wrap up today we do have a
bonus show today we will be off for the
next two days because of the
thanksgiving holiday and then we will be
back on monday i will be joining you
remotely on monday from the University
of Massachusetts in Amherst where I will
be teaching a course and thus will be
joining Pat remotely but that's not it
for the week if you remember you can go
to david pakman.com slash membership and
sign up and that will give you instant
access to the bonus show which is next